and welcome everybody i am pradeep
khosla I'm the Dean of the College of
Engineering and welcome to the CIT
leadership speaker series today is the
inaugural speaker series for the whole
series is the first time we are ever
doing it and I'm really happy and
excited and proud to welcome one of our
very own a pittsburgher or Carnegie
Mellon alarm dr. Aris kendra's but
before I give the stage to him let me
say a few more words about the speaker
series the whole idea of the speaker
series is to serve as a catalyst for
bringing together internationally
renowned thought leaders and Carnegie
Mellon faculty students and alumni and
clearly i can see that that is happening
i see in this audience a lot of faculty
i see a lot of some alumni and i see
some students to the second goal of this
is to discuss critical topics that are
of contemporary interest not only to
Carnegie Mellon but to the world at
large and in which Carnegie Mellon has
an important role to play or has
something to say and you can very well
imagine that the topic of today's talk
or conversation is something that
Carnegie Mellon excels in and has
excelled in for a very long time we
built what I think of as a spectacular
program in energy and unfortunately it's
not nuclear energy it used to be nuclear
energy and as soon as I introduce air is
a little bit more you will see that we
had a program in that area but we don't
but we do have everything else except
nuclear energy and we do have a lot of
enablers for nuclear energy like
material science like a better systems
and a whole lot of other things except
the core nuclear energy program itself
our energy strategy has been around for
about I would say more than 25 years ed
Rubin who's in the audience would be who
will be on the panel very soon
was one of the leaders and creators of
our strategy a long time ago but most
recently in the last five years or so we
have focused more heavily on our energy
strategy and we have built what I think
of as a leading relationship and a
spectacular relationship with any TL
which is the National Energy Technology
Laboratory right here in South Park and
that strategy has been led by Andy
Gelman who's also on the panel and that
strategy is beginning to pay off
dividends where we have now a five
University Consortium Carnegie Mellon
West Virginia University University
pittsburgh penn state and virginia tech
working with any TL on about a 20
million dollar a year program to build
all sorts of energy technologies and to
position ourselves not just our
universities but the country for the
future let me say a little bit about dr.
Aris canvas Eric Andrus is the CEO of
Westinghouse Electric Company and
Westinghouse Electric Company has been a
leader in providing nuclear solutions
both in the US and abroad and I think
when we hear eras talk we will know how
much business they're doing abroad in
1957 when the company developed
developed its first commercial nuclear
reactor Westinghouse is focused on
creating sustainable energy a goal that
is shared by Carnegie Mellon and I
assume the rest of the world as
president and CEO of Westinghouse and as
an as an alumnus of CIT in 74 and 78 dr.
Aris kendra's is a passionate is very
passionate about the role of nuclear
power and his master's and PhD are both
in the area of nuclear engineering which
used to be as a part of mechanical
engineering at Carnegie Mellon eres
began his career at Westinghouse in 1975
as a senior engineer in the advanced
reactor division and over the years he's
worked himself up the ladder and on July
first 2008 he was appointed the CEO I
think it's reasonable to say he's one of
the few people I know who's had this
career a spectacular career in one
company for the last 35 years in this
day and age you don't find that many
people of that
ilk Eris has a ba in physics math and
engineering from Transylvania University
and a master's and PhD from Carnegie
Mellon he is a member recently appointed
to the scene Carnegie Mellon Board of
Trustees but his more important
appointment is to the CIT deans council
that he attends more often so having
said that dr. Harris canvas thank you
for the it's always a pleasure to come
back to familiar surroundings here at
CMU and this is clearly an honor for me
just make sure that these paperwork is
out of the way what I want to do here is
pretty much set the stage for the
discussion that I'm hoping is going to
take place when the rest of us take our
seats around the table and make sure
that this gets a little bit more
interactive so pardon me if I rush
through an awful lot of data and
information but my purpose here is
primarily to share some information with
with the rest of the group so we're all
in the same page first of all energy
demand is growing going through in the
developed world a lot of efforts to
conserve and those efforts need to
continue but we need to maintain a lot
of awareness that the rest of the world
is not at the same level as the US and
Western Europe in particular and those
countries have a need a desire and
they're moving along the lines of
emulating what we've set up in the last
hundred years or so so the demands are
going to continue being there and you
see some of the numbers they are 100
million vehicles between that are going
to be coming online by 2020 in in China
alone and all those who contribute to an
overall growth in energy consumption by
2030 that some around fifty percent
higher than what it is today so that by
the way takes a significant amount of
conservation in the developed world into
account so that couple with the needs
that we have in order to work to make
sure that to preserve in
and improve the environment the much
more recent pressures on constraining
co2 emissions in particular can the
limit our options in terms of what we
can do as I said before conservation
clearly needs to part to be part of the
solution but it cannot be the solution
going forward we do need a lot more
balance in how we generate power around
the world china for example generates
the vast majority of its power right now
from from coal we're not all that far
behind we about fifty percent of our
power still comes from coal in this
country then you have on the other end
of the spectrum countries like France
with their eighty-five percent in a
nuclear generation so the balance need
to change significantly if we're going
to have the growth that we need to have
and still keep an eye towards the
environment and then start shifting the
uses of somewhat traditional fuels
especially fossil fuels and petroleum or
particularly but with the use of
electric vehicles in the future and I
think that trend is it's going forward
let me give you some statistics on the
current available sources in the
environment a lot of people for example
don't know that right now three-quarters
of all the co2 free power that was
generating the US comes from nuclear
power the other quarter or so comes from
hydro contribution from solar and wind
at least so far as you can see they are
fairly small similarly sometimes going
to debate these sources we lose track of
what we mean by by pollution
contribution you see some relatively
unfamiliar statistics up on the board
here be a you know the expectation and
the impression among the general public
generally speaking is that solar and
wind don't have much of a contribution
well when you consider
construction-related pollution and
manufacturing related pollution in the
equation you see for example that
natural gas
is can be better in some ways of of
solar photovoltaic and so on down here
down the line clearly hydro continuous
tour to be a very good source but it's
very limited in terms of availability
going forward same thing on course in
these statistics always have to be
careful when you quote statistics and
especially from your end a lot more
careful when you read them because
they're as Disraeli used to say they're
lies damn lies and statistics so in this
particular case these are statistics
from installed capacity so when you look
at installed solar installed wind and so
on down the line there is significant
difference in in generating costs
nuclear by the way for installed
generation has been for last ten years
or so the cheapest way across the board
in in the US and most other places well
part of the reason for that again in
order to make sure all operating the
same data is that capacity factors of
nuclear are very high they didn't used
to be.we it took us a while to get to we
are right now back in the in the 80s and
even early 90s we're still struggling in
the sixty to seventy percent capacity
factors we're now consistently over
ninety percent and have been for the
past ten years as a result of that the
costs are going down and the reliance is
going up but you see the rest of
Statistics there another piece of
information that needs to be
communicated is in the case of nuclear
in the case of hydro in the case of wind
in the case of solar capacity factor and
availability is about the same that does
not hold true for gas especially but
also for coal and oil we don't run those
units whenever they are available for
for obvious reasons because of course
and pollution so the bottom line if
there's one message that want to leave
with this group is I'm not appeared to
advocate that we should shut everything
down and build nuclear power plants but
the need for a lot more balance in our
mix going for
and having said that let me now go to an
area that know a little bit more about
them than the other and that's nuclear
and kind of run you through what i call
a nuclear primer here in terms of some
of the things that have changed in the
last few years back in the 70s okay
which is basically some of the bullets
that you see up here we had we're making
it up as we're going along both in
design as well as regulation of the
industry a lot of changes as a matter of
fact 104 nuclear power plants that we
have in the u.s. right now none of them
has identical design within any other of
the plants even on the same site you
walk to one of the units and you go to
the new unit next door differences in
design the reason is that we were
basically completing the designs
improving the designs expanding the
designs and the air and the output of
these units as the units were being
built it didn't help with regulation it
certainly didn't help with construction
costs and construction schedules
regulation was also something was fairly
new and were making it up as we went
along in the midst of that Three Mile
Island happened which added escalated
quite a bit the amount of regulation the
industry we learned quite a bit from
that actually at the time that it
happened it was totally catastrophic it
stopped basically dead in its tracks
nuclear expansion in the in the late 70s
early 80s but in retrospect is probably
the best thing that that happened for
the industry we learn quite a bit from
not only from the accident but also in
terms of operations as you see in the
bullet there a lot of the operators in
that bought those units in the late 60s
and early 70s but it is another way of
boiling water for the turban okay and
generating steam obviously this is a
little bit more complicated than a gas
turbine plan or a fossil unit of any
kind that they had before or even more
so a hydro unit and it's taken a while
for the industry or they took a while
for the industry to catch up with that
and and I was absolutely delighted that
when we had the problems in the Gulf and
we looked at what was missing in terms
of regulation of that industry just
about everybody whose knowledge about
how different
this is regulated in the u.s. turn and
said you need to take the example of how
nuclear industry regulated itself after
three mile island so a lot of lessons
learned is the bottom line and the most
important one is in the area of
construction I'll give you some examples
of that in a couple of slides obviously
we've made a lot of strides since then
today nuclear power in the u.s. is is
about twenty percent it's a little less
than that worldwide's about sixteen
seventeen percent but that percentage is
going up because the law developing
world is building a lot of nuclear units
right now the about fifty nine units
under construction as we speak china
alone is going to be putting another
probably 80 units between now and 2020
under construction so we're going to get
to the states with Chinese basically
putting almost a unit a month online of
nuclear units but back to this slide
here at the same time the regulatory
process which took time in the in the
hiatus that we had available to us in
the 80s and 90s to work with a regulator
and develop a much more streamlined
process for this plan so right now if
you have a licensed a pre license design
in a pre license site the when you put
those two together the opportunity for
intervention and the uncertainty
associated with that is very limited so
the utilities can get to a stage where
they basically start building the plant
if they almost have a hundred percent
assurances at that plant is not going to
have any additional regulatory hiccups
down the road the designs have improved
a lot I'll show you again in a minute
some examples of the type of
simplifications for example who put in
our design as a result of the
development that took place in the 60s
and 70s and then three mile island we
put an awful lot of regulatory mandated
band-aids on me on the original design
we took a look at that and basically
changed it drastically we also have a
track record didn't have before it we
now have several thousand plan years of
safe operation of nuclear power in
Western world and then advances in in
marginal construction and other
construction techniques have
significantly improved our chances of
delivering these bunis on one time and
on budget let me get a little more
technical on you I promise I won't go
too far into the details but what you
see on the left is what we're left with
after three mile island and a number of
other changes that taken care place
before that in the center is what
basically generates the steam that goes
out to the turbine generator in that
gray box all the rest that you see
around it is pumps valves piping diesel
generators that was added on in order in
case of an accident to maintain a cool
about geometry in the reactor in other
words keep the plant cooled and safe for
for the rest of the time what you have
on the right is whether the same plant
basically looks like now that's the
Westinghouse design by the way so it's a
little different than the rest of it
more simplified than the rest we
basically have done away with all the
active systems for safety and rely on
two things gravity and convection and it
still took us about 100 million dollars
to prove to the regulator that water
does still flow downhill still but it
was money well spent the design is a lot
simpler as you can tell them before and
again the fact that it is simpler
contributes to shorter construction
times as well as cheaper operations and
more streamlined operations going
forward shorter schedules of
construction what you see here is
basically some of the other things that
we decided to upgrade during that hiatus
period between Three Mile Island roughly
and a few years ago when the nuclear
resurgence came back I talked about the
licensing upgrades we also found out
when we're building the first generation
of plants that an awful lot of the
schedule issues and cost overruns were
associated with the with the
construction itself in other words the
fact that you're building such a complex
plant out in the open in the elements
and you have to spend several years
there will usually
in labor does not help so what we try to
do is minimize that so now we build most
of the plant in a factory environment we
build it in modules those modules are
transported to the to the site and that
simplifies construction improves the
quality control obviously because you're
doing it in in a factory environment and
reduces uncertainty overall one example
of that and in one example of the
simplifications I was talking about
earlier in terms of going to passive
systems is the overall reductions in in
the hardware and it can be as drastic as
piping we have eighty percent less
piping in this plant and a standard all
plant or a competitive plan right now
and eighty-five percent less cabling
obviously a lot of it has to do with
going to weigh and see from analogue
systems just be a absolutely transparent
but again a lot of less concrete a lot
less pumps and valves which again
reduces costs reduces construction
schedule uncertainty the first of these
four units are in the construction right
now in China they are scheduled for
completion in 2013 and you see some of
the pictures here are obviously
construction progress pictures but then
in the one in the lower center as well
as here you basically see one of these
modules being put into the inside what's
called the containment building and just
to give you an idea of scale because
it's very hard to lose sight of that
that's about six story building
equivalent that's the white portion
that's being lowered in there okay so a
lot of large modules that being
structured constructed now off-site and
being brought in again improving
schedule certainty as well as quality of
construction so not not your father's
nuclear power plant is that for those
who remember that that ad from
Oldsmobile a few years ago in terms of
where we are globally first in the US 22
about 11 12 utilities to be precise have
stepped forward and asked the NRC to
start the regulatory process six of
those have advanced enough to have
engineering procurement construction
contracts under completed already all
six of them by the way are for AP 1000s
the Westinghouse design so very happy
there are the ones that you see with an
asterisk there four of those are under
construction right now the non-nuclear
portion of the construction is already
started the nuclear construction is
going to start about this time next year
the rest of the world is really where
the majority of the of the story is
right now we have been contacted by no
less than about 50 different countries
who want to start a nuclear program over
there and clearly we're not chasing all
50 of them but there are some that have
established or in the process of
establishing very robust programs in
place both manufacturing as well as the
regulatory component of that and you see
some of them over here let me give you
an idea of what I'm talking about so you
get a pretty balanced view of what the
nuclear world is going to look like and
that's going to preamble to the
discussion we're going to have as a
group later on this is where the
concentration of nuclear plants is right
now as I said you have about 100 4 units
in the US exactly 100 4 units a matter
of fact not about there are generating
about twenty percent of the electricity
you have countries like France with
about eighty five percent of the
electricity being nuclear and you see a
lot of concentration in France Western
Europe in general Sweden Germany Spain
Belgium UK large percentages in the 30s
or so of the generation is nuclear and
then you go in the Far East Korea Japan
Taiwan again in the 30s in terms of
nuclear generation that's the current
picture then you fast forward to 2030
what you're going to basically add
another fifty percent to the current
generation and you see a slight shift a
lot more in Asia
and.and than before but clearly not
enough by comparison to what are the
plans for 2050 where you see a total
shift in the balance of nuclear
generation a lot more in Western Europe
but in Western Europe is very densely
populated the same thing holds true for
Japan and Korea and Taiwan but the big
story is India and China where they have
made already commitments for significant
increase of of installed capacity as I
mentioned earlier the Chinese in
particular have a very specific program
of nuclear construction and they're
going to stick to it and of course you
see places that we haven't been before
Africa for example in Southeast Asia and
so on so at some point based on current
plans part of what we need as a country
to look at is whether we're going to
stay relevant in this debate if you know
the nuclear power plants in in the u.s.
represent two percent of the population
of nuclear units around the world we're
not going to be particularly relevant in
the debate and won't ever as big a vote
as we have right now so in summary
clearly we need to have means of meeting
our energy needs that are safe and
environmentally agreeable we do need to
continue advancing renewable sources but
we also need to stay balanced in terms
of on making sure that we also have the
bedrock of our current generation
capability which is the the base load
plans and continue to make an a shift to
more environmentally friendly base load
in order to be able to meet some of the
rather lofty I think especially in the
Western world goals that have put in
place for for reduce co2 generation
going forward thank you very much and
when we sit down as a panel have an
opportunity to answer all questions I'm
sure from all of you thank you
so what we're going to do is I'm going
to introduce a panelists will briefly
and as I say your name please come and
take your seat I guess even before that
please and I'm going to start with a
couple of questions that I have and then
open it up to the audience and if you
don't have enough questions I'll fill
the hole so first let me introduce dr.
any government who's the department head
of chemical engineering he is also the
founding director of the Institute for
Advanced Energy Solutions which is the
name of her partnership with any TL that
I was mentioning earlier next is dr. ed
Rubin who's the alumni professor of
engineering and public policy and
mechanical engineering he serves on the
NRC committee studying climate change
mitigation policies and energy R&D
planning and transportation technologies
and he was the member of the IPCC that
wrote the report for which Al Gore and
the IPCC got the Nobel Prize dr. J
Whittaker next to him is the is an
assistant professor material science and
EP p and his current research focuses on
synthesizing and implementing promising
materials and device architectures for
energy storage he is on leave this year
doing a start-up to look at a new class
of batteries are going to be really
cheap and free for everybody and we can
store the energy ah with that in mind
let me start with aris that was a very
interesting and an illuminating talk
where I didn't quite appreciate how much
nuclear how many nuclear power plants
are being built across the world and I
was always under the impression that
there is a big push back by society in
general against nuclear power plants so
given that impression especially in the
US and given what you are predicting out
here what is it that needs to be done to
educate or inform or make people more
aware of the positive attributes of
nuclear power what is the Westinghouse
doing and in that context how can
Carnegie Mellon be of any help or use to
Westinghouse both in generation
biology and yes that personal we start
with who the last part so these are one
I mean 40 like this are important to get
the word out so appreciate what you guys
already doing in help you get the word
out of this song yes it okay but because
going back to the beginning of your
question one of the biggest problems
that we've had in this industry and it's
some problem we created quite frankly is
we do not communicate enough for the
general public early on in the sixties
and seventies they were folks in white
lab coats than working on nuclear power
and figure this is too complicated get
out there and explain to a mountain Papa
a bunch of housewives absolutely wrong
wrong tack and we still are doing
ourselves as a service but not moving on
from a lot more aggressive in
communication I having said that the
statistics especially in the US are
worth more encouraging that youth in
spite of a poor job done most of the
American public has gotten the word and
the general acceptance of nuclear in an
all-time high right now a lot of it has
to do with the fact that finally the
word got out
do not generate them any co2 gases were
in a dark illusion of a kind but even
before that it was a slow recognition
especially with years of experience and
an operation record behind us that these
planets are indeed safe good neighbors
and can be a family run very profitable
level so right now we general acceptance
of nuclear in the u.s. somewhere in the
seventy percent rate was significantly
higher than what used to be a few years
ago what is even more telling is if you
go to the areas with the nuclear plants
are the acceptance rate is well over
eighty percent and then there's not
include the focus is working on a
platform associatively utility so those
folks have been working and living
coming to be living and experiencing
close up the plan is a neighbor from the
feel pretty good about along with it
answer by think that now that's actually
very useful I didn't realize the except
on rates or that hi Andy let me ask you
a question I know you're leading this
effort with any TL so we heard errors
talk about the port about an energy
future that seemed to me was going to be
like a portfolio of energy energy energy
technology that not just a or b or c and
i know you had visions about that in
terms of what you're doing with any TL
can you tell us a little bit about what
would that portfolio look like how long
would it take to get there so yeah I
think
the reality is the portfolio terminology
is the right one and the fact is it's
going to take about hundreds of years to
get to a point where we're in some sort
of steady state so my view of the energy
world is that we are where we are today
which is largely seventy eighty percent
fossil-based energy and twenty maybe
thirty percent other sources there has
to be a transition over the course of
time because fossil resources are
limited although truthfully they could
last for hundreds of years and given the
wrong economic pressures they will last
for hundreds of years so over the course
of a few hundred years you have to have
a transition from fossil-based to
something else and something else has to
be either renewable or at least
something that would be an energy source
that exists for as long as civilization
wants to exist so and I personally
suspected the real time frames were
getting to a point of sustainability my
grades up over two or three hundred
years so that's very interesting I think
that kind of relates to so let me give
you a reader statistic for you in this
is from the US Energy Information
Administration report in 1980 fossil
fuels were ninety percent of the total
power generation in 2006 26 years later
they were only they were not only there
were 86.2 percent so there was hardly
any movement of the needle as one would
say right a nuclear power in ad was
two-point-six percent and nuclear power
in 2006 is five point nine percent this
is across the whole world right so it's
interesting that you say it would take a
couple of hundred years I can very well
imagine at this rate it is going to take
a couple of hundred years at let me ask
you the following so if we then think
about couple of hundred years and if we
think about keeping on emitting co2 in
the meantime because fossil fuel is a
dominant fuel our president and the
senior leadership have laid down this
rule of this vision of reducing co2
emissions by eighty percent how are we
going to do it and how fast can we do it
we're deep were we not to get along with
this topic cries out for most of the
game with the climate issue with the
eight percent abilities important
contest that organ come from the
administration came from the I bcc of
scientists study climate change and what
they're suggesting is that the world our
beverages to reduce its emissions
greenhouse gases eighty percent here's
the Richard not in 200 years but that's
40 by mid-century 2050 why to avoid what
appear to be serious consequences of
climate warming we dump the
administration has adopted thats a
policy they didn't succeed this year in
getting the state of California did
state of California in fact has a policy
that would reduce greenhouse gas
emissions for eighty percent by 2050
very ambitious that driver is probably
one of the strongest reasons for
renaissance of nuclear power because it
is one of the few which already pointed
out near zero emitters of co2 but I also
want to make sure that we don't leave
the room when we talk about energy I
tend to focus on energy supplies I think
about energy i start with energy demand
if you think about how to reduce co2
emissions significantly and the only
truly clean energy i know of is energy
that we don't use everything else has
some vantage and so the first place to
start for reducing the machines in
reducing demand for just electricity
energy across the board and the u.s. is
the obvious place to start where of less
than five percent of the world's
population we produce something like
fifteen percent of the world's energy
and we consume over twenty percent of
the world's energy we can do better and
that we know how to do it the flag for
political will so energy efficiency and
energy conservation is the place to
start switching from high carbon to low
carbon fuels coal to natural gas can
bring us halfway nuclear along with
renewals have a very strong potential
role but again all of these other things
have other types of impacts at the
fourth option that stays a lot of play
two hours of technology called carbon
sequestration capturing and putting
carbon dioxide deep underground as a
strategy for at least several decades
and can deal with the monstrament of
Colin's reviews so it's all going to
depend I think a lot on policy it's not
going to be easy to do it may not even
be possible to start soon there's a
major challenge out there so thanks but
I want to come back to this in a second
because I still I'm confused one of you
says it's going to take 200 years for a
transition and you are going to reduce
co2 by eighty percent in 20 years it
seems to me then the transition
shouldn't take that long but I'll come
back to that would think about it but I
want to get to J Whittaker in the
meantime so if I were to believe this
portfolio of energy strategy as in
multiple sources of energy clearly smart
grid is going to play an important role
and clearly as I look at the pictures
that errors was showing intermittent
energy sources would have to have
storage capability so can you say
something about what are we doing in
terms of new materials new batteries how
cheap are they going to be how
affordable are they going to be in terms
of large-scale storage are we going to
get there or we not of course
in a couple hundred years that's cool oh
no and so yes yes your question is
appropriate obviously for working on and
the answer is there are many compete as
a whole portfolio terrific approaches as
there are in many emerging energy
technology whole portfolio of possible
solutions are battling it out right now
for dominance many of them are based on
what I consider to be technically
superior solutions that are also
economically severely disadvantaged and
the people who are going to win at the
end of the day are those who will keep
the performance of storage on a dollars
per kilowatt hours delivered over the
lifetime of the device and if you cannot
compete with pumped hydro which is I've
got two cents or three cents a kilowatt
a whore on you oh we are are we might
have a shot because the only competition
there are giant Lakes essentially but
the real competitor right now are
stationary put up to be run once in a
while what are called people plants
these are large gas turbines that cost
the neuter is 702 a thousand dollars per
kilowatt hour installed and they run on
natural gas these are what we really
have for energy storage right now the
large wind farm goes down and quickly
loses its
sibilities power because the wind is
curtailed they spin up these turbines to
buffer out and to level out the demand
and if you can instead make a energy
storage device that will deliver energy
over a three to six hour time frame you
might be able to offset some of this so
the price point has to be from some kind
of battery level something that's under
here in august or a while to put that in
perspective and it has to last in 10 to
15 years and it has to be able to have
very good rounds of energy efficiency
right these are very tall to management
a place on these materials in the
sanitation so it's not is anyone there
yet no no one is right now but acid
batteries are cheap enough they don't
last lithium ion batteries have a good
performance but they're two or three
times that expensive and they also have
difficult thermal range they can't get
that hot which you hold and consistent
if everyone
so but there's four or five emerging
solutions that are going to be able to
compete and maybe make a difference
we'll see what happens but everyone is
sort of edging closer and closer to this
cost point it starts with do your
material systems that you're working
with at a raw materials level can you
scale them the right cost point can you
insert them in a system of the balance
of system is also not that expensive and
then can you stack up against a
competing technology like a natural
gas-fired turbine you can't do those
things you're not going to link so it's
going to be a long time we're out there
trying to thank I'm going to open
this up to the audience that pose one
more question but go ahead if you
already go for it actually there are
microphones in the so there's one to my
left knee of that window and there's one
to my right out here near the window so
while you're walking up there let me
pose a question to the whole panel out
here so if I look at the strength of
Pittsburgh clearly Westinghouse right in
our backyard is a great strength n et al
on the other side or other backyard is a
spectacular strength Carnegie Mellon
University of Pittsburgh Penn State in
the to our vicinity WBU or other great
strengths so I'd like you to tell us a
little bit about what do you see as an
economic development opportunity that we
could be exploiting what role can
Pittsburgh have in the energy future of
the world
myself sail under our feet here apt and
other companies console is also both the
poll now and turn the gas business so
part of what we're trying to do is
basically get us all together since
we're all trying to do acetate for
improvements in this area motion
Frenchman fabricate for this area to be
regarded as the Houston new history of
the US and was telling to get some
traction we do have a group of companies
that comprises all these areas that get
together periodically and try to
supplant along these lines and try to
project Pittsburgh in this light and
includes not only the that's additional
sources that wins over and smart grid
some of the other more innovative and
newer technologies or something to
spring up some of them as a result of
seeing you and pick being in the area
and people want to stick sticks around
so we are as opposed to doing that they
can see some people back there that have
some affiliation of that group so we'll
keep trying what about startups jr. I
know you're involved we need to do
whatever we can to lure there's a lot of
money out and say the valley mainly
right now I new venture funds or venture
funds are starting new funds explicitly
for developing nuclear energy
technologies it is a lot of money out
there they're billion billion
multi-billion dollar funds and video
looking actively for people and ideas
and concepts both for growth investment
as well as education investment and we
need to continue to court this kind of
thing because more we establish in the
region and we have to make through these
companies keep the roots that's what is
that that's another and what are we
doing about any policy that we could
give some advice to dan onorato and
company anybody from his office here I
hope so pushy person expensive solar
technology over somewhere I also invited
but we were at that position I think
that's another as a third circle
cardigan on both especially injured of
the policy department longer well
established history attractive look
sensibly across the spectrum of policy
options and he does natl have it on its
plan to see some companies do transition
any comments there may be more than
happy to take any technologies well
around here and I think what are they
one of the potential dope values of
having five universities
that five universities each of which has
its own independent intellectual
property portfolio on the NBL if we were
able to organize things well enough to
say from here each from here peeps from
here and suddenly put together a new
technology deputy options or affect them
on any group of universities that would
be incredibly valuable exercise thanks
Andy I see lines forming on both sides
so just one piece of advice make it a
real question very crest because I would
like to get to all of you and maybe more
people just your name and the question
please s'okay I'm dawn fire Smith I
worked at the software engineering is to
the questions for dr. canvas what is the
nuclear industry doing in general in
Westinghouse in particular with regard
to securing nuclear plants from cyber
terrorism and cyber warfare and we've
already seen in destroying turbines from
the outside and that you can't build
them very fast for for the current
generation of plants even though they
are things that we're doing we can't we
talk about it but I can tell you that a
50,000 foot level there are a lot more
renewed a lot of other parts of
infrastructure because unfortunately
they be using six technology for I NC
which is not as susceptible to intrusion
network controller is something more
important about having renewed our
infrastructure in the last 30 years so
going forward clinics it's a it's a
design criteria it's something that
we're looking at that looked at even
before it became fashionable as my fact
we are working with CMU among others in
order to make sure to put for us patrons
our place interesting enough by the way
comes to security in general right after
911 those are a big flurry of activities
by the federal government to look at our
infrastructure as a fall and the David
devised some sort of a scale ABCD in
terms of grades that you got nuclear
power plants was the safest part of our
infrastructure Barnum and Sarah seems to
me that have been sei and Scilab you
have every all the solutions at home go
no further I was just wondering why
isn't the press of the Iranian metal
rising
commodities I understand and
decommissioning upon weapons as part of
that my second question is what's the
plan B for the waste after that's
declined Yucca Mountain good question i
guess the Bulls of meat oh yeah the
price price of the uranium is partly for
the reason that you mentioned the
federal government is taking both us and
non-us weapons-grade uranium and down
blending it metric Westinghouse's is
doing most of that and using it in the
commercial clients and that obviously
keeps the price overall now but in
general uranium is no scare resource
there's a lot of is conception about
that that probably spend some of the
cartoons back in fishes so it is not all
that susceptible even if you were let me
just cost that further there was a time
when there was a spike in the price he
went from about ten dollars 140 about
three years ago or so and stayed there
for a few months and came back down
crashed but even during that period of
time it didn't affect the cost of
militaries to generate it from nuclear
because the cost of fuel is a very small
component of these plants and Game
people one of the reasons that utilities
like these units is they're not
susceptible to these types of price
fluctuations that we have a gas prices
and the like let me go to the second
part it's probably more interesting I
keep correcting people apologize for
doing that to you but it's not the
nuclear waste it's actually spent fuel
than for healing and a big very big
distinction what comes out of these
plants still has about eighty-five
percent of its energy content in there
so a one screw system the ones
you know adoptive to the house in the US
and spirit visit right now is almost a
crime that you put that much usable
energy you know and bearing the way for
political reasons to make a long story
short the inter-mountain at least for
now appears to be sidelined and a lot
more optimistic and my common thing with
you again too many newspapers because I
think that's going to come back and be
unavailable part of this part of the
available solution but in general I
think we need to be going back and
looking at how we closed the most
effective way the fuel cycle France is
doing it with Westinghouse and US
technology and I've been doing for a
number of years and we need to go down a
similar path another okay to use the
same technology we've come a long way
since then this is technology developed
in 60s but we're now looking in the u.s.
there is a blue ribbon commission it's
been established as a result of the
political decision in Yucca Mountain and
part of the recommendation is how do you
burn this fuel differently how do you
reduce the actinides in the fuel which
is the long the bad actors and if you
will who can do that
nology now and how do you develop your
technology to reprocess and recycle that
fuel okay eventually you will have some
ways it's a very small portion of it by
the way the whole misconception about
waste in general I was telling somebody
earlier than one of the reasons that
when I was a long-haired hippie here on
this campus back in the early seventies
I went to nuclear engineering is because
when you look at it's the only source of
power available to us large scale that
can truly deal with its waste they sum
total of the waste from 104 plans that
we have now after 40 years of operation
is about a football field 20 25 it's
less than one year's coal ash from a
large hole faucet plan and people
sometimes lose sight of these numbers we
have the luxury of waiting and finding a
much more elegant solution 100 years ago
who could even spell you peel hunt years
from now god only knows what's going to
be available in terms of Technology
going in and very once through this
spent fuel and ground as I said before
it is not the right solution yes sir you
mentioned previously a shell call a
shale deposit so that were available and
I don't worry do you think to be
available e the increased availability
of fossil fuels up and down on
sustainable resources will impede the
development of maybe
I can tell you definitely with the low
price of gas in this country is delayed
the next construction of the goons in
the US in a sense that's unfortunate
because this is short-term thinking
versus long-term solutions and kind of
advocates for what area was talking
about it may take us about 100 years or
so to get this right that is not an
issue and it's not a factor outside the
US gas shale gas it from very a u.s.
gift and I think by the time we're all
said and done and truly identify the
true cost of extracting shale gas and
healing some will be a pollution issues
such a good there's a lot such thing as
a free lunch so right now we're dealing
with almost like we were dealt with
nuclear power back in the 50s over
several scoochie convenor ok so we gas
is not going to games being impacted the
right now yes the overabundance of gas
and oil prices affecting decisions let's
see on this side I'd like to give eres
arrest for one question does anybody
have a question which is not for error
so you can recover his voice it guess
not it's your turn go for it yeah my
name is more inflation key student and
engineering and public policy and I
studied public perceptions of low-carbon
electricity generating technologies and
I just actually wanted to get your
reaction to something I really
specifically interested in people's gaps
and misconceptions about different
energy technologies and I agree with you
that nuclear has become more accepted by
the general public though I wouldn't
paint as rosy a picture as you would
because I just did a study with 58 sign
six through 12th grade science teachers
in the area and I asked them a true or
false question the question was nuclear
power plants release no co2 it's in the
air a quarter of the science teachers
answered incorrectly and about twenty
percent
answer said they did not know and this
is the science teacher so you know the
message is you know is out there but not
at the level i think that you would want
and it's also it's something that you
know we have to watch what we think
people know and i wanted to get your
reaction to this I've heard this before
or not that people actually think that
you clear power plants release co2
absolutely yes I've heard that I'm also
quite aware that there's a lot of
information gap and that's why I add
that answer the question early on that
would things we need to do a love better
talking communicating and especially
targeted groups like science features
that ought to know better see ya I'm
burger tolan from University of
Pittsburgh I do writing and speaking on
behalf
your power the end of pushback I get
that I have trouble with was in the cost
you seem to say that the cost has been
going down but several years ago it was
two or three thousand dollars per
kilowatt l are talking five to eight
dollars per thousand dollars per
kilowatt what's going on why is it costs
keep going up that way wait this is the
installation costs of building the plan
I just want to make it clear to write
and first of all on the construction
costs the numbers are out they are not
always correct okay the numbers that
were older early on probably
pollyannaish with by the industry is not
question about it on top of that we had
an across-the-board increase in material
concrete has gone up significantly still
has gone up across the board it's
affected that wood structure of all
kinds of infrastructure but obviously
were the beneficiaries of that as well
having said that some of the numbers
that are being coded now in their 40 by
our customers obviously we can't step
out there and say you these numbers are
wrong it includes a whole bunch of the
infrastructure and contingency that they
as pluton project managers have to put
in on their books before they go to the
PUC so the numbers that you quoted
includes a lot of the overnight
construction costs of the plan itself
putting additional lines into the plan
building roads building
building to support the planet there
take the transmission and transformers
and so on so it is significantly higher
than the I mean those costs those
atoms that be there connecting
non-nuclear facility as well they
distort a little bit depiction from the
numbers that were originally fully just
as overnight cost for any plans the
overnight costs right now for it for a
planet in most Western countries
somewhere in the neighborhood for our
you need someone to make about 4,000 we
hope you get it back down to 2500 by the
way so we're going to finish about five
minutes and then we'll have a reception
so you'll have a chance to meet with
errors on a personal basis before i get
to you let me pose with a panel a
question on smart grid that's an issue
we have not talked about if you look at
this multi-source enable the future
clearly Smart Grid technologies have to
play a critical role in enabling
managing the power all the time so eras
let me start with action on let me start
with J and come to errors because I want
to know what Westinghouse is doing about
it but before I get there let's start
with actually add he's been quiet for a
while do you think the smart grid is has
any reasonable chance of happening in
the next 10 years or 20 years I want to
see what your prediction is about the
smart grid smart you want to be so
imagine a great where power is being
auctioned in real time and where people
are buying and selling power literally
from their houses much per diem is that
conceptually the notion is is good we
know where we ultimately we like to get
to to do this on march
our time is opposed us for any any
limitation we're talking about this
technology that can enable all sorts of
things you can do now anything from
moderating appliances that are they used
home to buildings to reduce energy
demand to be able to have the
fluctuations and intermittent sources
like when you knit solar which actually
makes basic technologies or if your
shoes but it's gonna take time this is
the right we're probably over doing
getting it started a little bad 10 or 20
years from now students in the back of
the room remind yourself to ask ask the
question in 20 years how smart is the
grid now and how dumb was it your
attendance so let me then go to j so
Jeff you're working on storage and you
think that's one of the key enablers
what capability is the smart grid need
to have to understand it needs to store
energy it needs to pump energy out at
what price it's storing at what prices
at selling how does it all work the neck
by me it's it's difficult it's one of
one of the questions that smart created
is not only how smart is it but I'm good
smart is it but also how distributed is
it right and the more distributed you
become more useful smaller storage bits
are and you know it within a given node
are you having a great deal better
communication between the nodes are you
just having one no take care of itself
at a very single link out between I mean
it may architectural guess what I'm
trying to stay in it's unclear which one
is going to be the dominant one and so
there are many development paths right
now some are looking on my site at
what's called community energy storage
which is 25 24
that it gave several households you
sorted out a block-level and these are
across the countryside what he was
looking at for example and then there
are other people like ABS you just want
to do multi like 10 20 100 megawatt hour
thanks as you know near the production
point or near luck major notes right
they're both valid they both require
different kind of intelligence and it
depends also on how interactive you want
the purchaser's the users the public to
me it might be that we put that opinion
and put a battery in our basement
instead it's 5 21 hours and we can
decide to use it for our own litter we
can decide to sell time from that
battery back to the grid right if that
is an answer then you have their great
build intelligence if you keep the
battery at the node level it's much too
so notice what about Westinghouse what
are you guys pessimistic as entity was
earlier nobody 100 200 years but i think
twenty years probably optimistic for the
u.s. one of the disadvantages that we
have for being innovators in this
country and have one of the oldest grins
as a result of that these will take
trillions of dollars literally you're
going to upgrade it to a point where it
can do everything we want to do like to
do with the first one great having said
that as that said nucleus is really a
beneficiary the level levelized demand
system that's exactly what a smart cream
is doing so we are waiting to open any
yemeni and go ahead to say in expert in
that have anything useful oh i see three
people waiting in line i am going to
predict their offer or eris all the
questions operators did I get that right
maybe not good thank you so let's start
with you and then we'll finish with two
out here and we'll be done so be quick
my name is Richard F lady mrs. for dr.
Harris for a typical
nuclear steam supply no that's excluding
the electric generation portion of a
place what portion of the construction
costs and the labor costs will be
uncertainty us that believeth what
portion will be a source inside the US
vs top story for the nuclear portion I
would like to say that some point would
be able to be at one hundred percent
right now because we left the
infrastructure not only nuclear but
across the board all the supporting it
was our profound reason and the life go
by the wayside inn last coin years we
can't do that so for example for the
large components that we need one piece
forgings we have to go outside of Japan
with Korea down the road even India the
UK and other countries are developing
that capability or still lagging behind
so right now probably about seventy
percent of the content is us-based the
rest of the collection
Colton present students civil
environmental engineering my questions
for anyone in the panel who can answer
this in laws to what is the future of
nuclear breeder reactors dr. Sanders was
talking about earlier not not doing just
the ones through what is the future of
that and how close are we to it well
since i started my career designing
those under the back 35 years ago i can
tell you that we've gone through the
first phase of development and the
actual operation posing the US and
specially overseas and we have a lot of
data from successful operation but in
terms of commercial operation of these
units i don't think any time at least in
the foreseeable future we're going to
see breeders are such an early because
the question is a story of pressure
uranium is too low we don't really need
to go into breeding which is generating
more material than where you're using I
think they do have a technology the
ability to operate on the other fast end
of the spectrum from chronic standpoint
has a definite application in our
ability to better utilize spent fuel
essentially as burners as opposed to do
to breeders last question my name is
john linnell no renewable energy
development also in a lot of the
you're at CMU and also else along as
well a nursing already answered half of
my question when you said that the price
of natural gas dropping delayed the
development of nuclear power I was can
ask about that and I was going to ask to
what extent does the US national policy
on carbon emissions affect your
predictions of growth would national
polity that's one appointment from the
point of view of an energy developer
arena lawyers about were those two
things I think kid Oakley those two
factors are the major factors affecting
for no wonder I wonder to what extent
nuclear was immune from that and it's
what extent they're also factors no I
don't think anything is immune from that
and I think when it comes to major
infrastructure and I'm an extreme when
it comes to economics from the extreme
right of that curve but when it comes to
infrastructure development there is a
role it has to be a role for some
centralized planning and right now
that's not a well structured value the
most polite way please join me in
thanking our panelists
we are now going to move right outside
this auditorium and there's a reception
there right across from this auditorium
and tongue our labs so please join us
thank you